il a qu'est ce qu'il en pense votre
frère rire la galerie ce qu'est ce qu'il
en pense votre frère alors le principe
est très simple vous connaissez un on
arrête des gens dans la rue leur pose
une question toute bête et pendant ce
temps là on a un camion à côté avec
plein d'accessoires et on va se déguiser
à peu près comme je suis déguisé sous
souvent valérie ça reste quand même dans
l'approximatif a déjà vu ça lara et
priscilla oui j'ai vraiment adoré ça est
bon pour partir avec la cassette tour à
cette cassette et la cassette de mathieu
valbuena avec le voilà tout tout tout ce
qu'il faut c'est parti avec plaisir rien
à vous mais le diamant
les eskimos à quoi toi plaisir qu'est ce
que vous pensez et ans ont en commun
parisiens plutôt du bien je n'ai pas de
voiture je n'en vois pas du tout
l'utilité habitant à paris est donc
d'accord et votre est il en pense quoi
eh bien je suis trésorier
oui bon bah je vois je suis tombé dans
le paddock caisse est triste et qui
pourrait sourire et se mettre à poil et
votre sale en pense quoi
et d'ajouter très bien que rire et que
toutes ces questions merci j'aime bien
les transports parisiens
je leurs animaux et votre elle en pense
quoi
jpost grosso modo la même et chaud
ménagez pas compris ce qui quand on
arrive à certaines périodes
il fait quand même assez chaud fait
assez froid et c'est vrai que d'accord
et votre sale en pense quoi même chose
c'est insupportable hamon données
transporte ans n'entend parler que de ça
c'est sa meilleure jamais s'améliorer
toit fait plaisir de te revoir
moi aussi c'est très long qu'attendu
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens
c'est pratique ça tu as you et vos
frères il en pense quoi
oui parce qu'il ya toujours un cola pour
sortait le corps va donner at il pris
quoi bien sûr frère à merde atomique